quando facciamo il vino non è il canale
in descrizione dei beni siamo armati vai
via vai via
signori prega il signore
allora c'è il bastardo di lorenzo che
pure piretti di merda è perché non lo so
che adesso due fg eto'o viene ammazzato
entrati per la macchina per la barca che
ogni volta che masochisti male che c'è
la barca ciccio è la giuria dei cento mi
metto a ridere né invece sola ti fa nera
che sfida ci sono ci senti leziosa no
nora che ciccio valle dalle possibili
sono tutti una casa e di fare dolce
picchio e tenacia drammi e tonico e cosa
stai facendo staccare la corrente no no
visto che stando io sono solo nell'altra
casa la giudico a dadini benecchi denti
basta iniziata ricordati che ti dunque
loro iscritti qui non farina non afferro
scusate eh caro
[Musica]
e arrivato sul partito barcollante anni
lontano nome di gesù cristo lontano ma
ma non è un esorcismo ritoccati le mani
le mani perché sono disabile di 13 gli
obiettivi a darmi una mano e chiatti
tappa all'istituto cercato con la
mistura
[Musica]
io ho paura ragazza video in alto ma
nessuno ha mai guardato a farmi jarvis
arrivando a volte venga proietto
ricordare i beni verso di me le rivali
luigino ieri vieni
ecco tito bene dove vado dove dice un
altro massimo previsto è scappato io mi
trovo in un cesso non mancando la mia
mamma cosa manca
manca la benzina il mio collo corto
mancati ma cosa vuoi da me ma ci sono
anche altri giocatori
la ci sono solo io e maschio solo io
stavo arti da un fitto tutti lo hai
visto tu stavi jailbreak e ciccio da
offrire un pover power e di un po ebbero
possiamo provare a batterlo dovrebbero
perché toni jarvis amore secondo me
[Musica]
[Applauso]
niente gli altri la famiglia non ha
grazie arrivo anche via milano marittima
no no no mi ami che sto per quasi cioè
no ti prego per quanti ci riceve prego
dai per bravo perverrà tutti ragazzi per
radio trova squartata di famiglia e io
ti do una chicca cielo chiuso formativo
a un gruppo di grande pregio è netto la
torino impianto mi preme ora guarda
cielo dove sei
allora quando facciamo il vino non è di
canali del trigno ne vediamo quanto
corri pantaloni con gesù io mi stanco
mai ma non c'è quanti cercano c dove si
apre delle porte del fondo hanno subito
diversi ma c'è il cucinino lì chi tu
vedi qua a iaia padre via loro filo
correndo
brigida aiuto animali di de vecchi carri
[Musica]
armati e l'altra sua ma chi è questo
hayden siamo armati vai via vai via
siete dei maledetti campani ma devi
scappare anima un albero
[Musica]
ma che mio zio ciccio ciao vicino una
curiosità e meritato brutto taglio verde
canala sordi a una mia rega che goduria
nel tagliare ciccio gamer in questo
momento ma il mio merenda lingue dover
italiani guarda che mi sono dimenticate
ciao raga io mi piace mi piace comunque
vabbè io sto girando con un paio di
chiavi e nient'altro anima animata marzo
prima lo vitaccia tranquillo amato prima
e basta che ti lascerà in un matri posto
non mi mancano
anima arriva tornando fede dei tool più
bello
hai visto mamma mia una merda vi dico e
ho augurato hamid armi per adobe jarvis
crediamo giovanni garbi vediamo che sarà
fantasia e la nota la gente dà anche il
titolo la morte ma io siamo amici
volevo voli e va beh li aspetta di torte
arrivare la gente così anima ma hanno
cessi me andrà a ogni jarvis che magari
di calarvi che la trappola intervenuti
marco è prima 5 morgan o me ne manca uno
solo che non so dove sia milan aiuto a
dentro una casa e di tora vero e proprio
lì ciao zio vediamo che quanto era per
capire se potrà cambiare un po il
tentativo è morta gli dice è aumentato
persone oggi mi sono divertito di quanti
ne ha fatti volare 6 cross per gli altri
perché spiega tuscia su ktm
i ragazzi perché non implicherà ho
registrato con touch e con ciccio
piccole trovate anche i due game play
loro l'alta velocità santanchè uscita ma
uscirà dal loro punto di vista e ciccio
però che vide olimpia ti aiuta ragazzi
come ha potuto vivere piaciuta al
momento è un inviate anche valente
covino a donare presidente di ci
mettiamo così unito
[Musica]
ecco